apparently a bullet ended up lodging
himself into his head but he didn't know
and the only reason why he realized it
is because he started having spasms in
his right arm so he went to the doctor
it's another one of those if it ended up
a few millimeters from where it actually
did land definitely could have caused
much more serious damage I kind of like
that every gunshot is like that well if
it was an inch to the left you would
have di any direction a foot South you
would have got your dick chopped off it
was 2 inches to the left you would have
forgot the alphabet we can't take the
bullet out or you'll turn Jewish you'll
become highly successful but it's
probably some Flex that doctors do this
is how much I know or does kind of make
you feel a lot better like oh my God
like I narrowly escaped death this is
how you break the news you give them
perspective of how bad it could have
been they're just like man if it was 6
in to the left you wouldn't have gotten
shot we would have never met I just be
some guy you wouldn't even know me